oui
[Musique]
et
allez donc
or
oh
et
où
attends attends là là là on vient si toi
allez
enfin
ça va si bien
ah bon
à
allez
est bonne même pas
tourner la page
d'abord
ça
c'est bon gars mais attention regardez
ce que vous fait faire
bon je continuais tranquille accor qui
vous tourner quand même
même pas sûr tout n'est pas bon à lui
reste à
faire
ah non il faut pas charrier pas mon
sandwich
on est partant voilà sa
valeur bondit n'ont pas
mené de me dire ne pas me gêner
et
abbott
adore entre le
je ne crois pas
il veut mon choix et la haine
ouais mais à présent
c'est pas grave alors
ça fait je suis pas du tout homosexuel
merci monopole
[Musique]